hello everyone
we will be starting with the session in
uh
ten more minutes
thank you for joining the session
in the meantime you can introduce
yourself in the chat box and let us know
about your educational background and
your research background as well
and uh we are looking forward to it
thank you
hello everybody
um
hello everyone our very warm good
morning good afternoon or good evening
in whichever part of the world you are i
would like to welcome you all to the
very first session of chem informatics
for biomedical drug discovery program
this program is designed to address the
challenges which are associated with
understanding modeling screening and
applying chemi informatics strategies to
improve drug discovery results the
process of finding a new drug against a
chosen target for a particular disease
usually involves high throughput
screening wherein large libraries of
chemicals are tested for their ability
to modify the target
with contributions from leading
researchers in academia and
biotechnology pharmaceutical industry as
well as experts from the software
industry this comprehensive mental
guided training program explains how kim
informatics enhances drug discovery
today we discuss about some of the
topics which are mentioned here which
includes the molecular structure of
biological macromolecules history and
techniques amino acid structure and
function protein structures primary
secondary tertiary quaternary structure
structural domain structural motif
protein subunit we'll also talk about
protein protein interactions
conformational analysis protein folding
sequence structure and function
relationship and we'll have a hands-on
session with biomolecular visualization
and finally an assignment for you all to
work on
so before we begin with today's session
as this is our first session i would
like to introduce us for those who have
joined us for the very first time
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
and we are working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omix project training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
in six different specialization tracks
which includes oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
chemi informatics for biomedic for bio
for biomedical job discovery
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
the omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
now getting back to the program
let's discuss how do omixologic
resources help in advancing
bioinformatics
so the omics logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics which includes various
omnic fields that we are covering data
science and structural biology i'll be
taking you through the portal and the
resources and what all you can
leverage from in just a while but before
that i would like to go through some of
the resources that you will have the
access to as a part of this program so
the omislogic portal is composed of
courses that are designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge the
omics logic takes a combination of
training modules that i just explained
data analysis tools curated project data
sets and interactive sessions with
mentors will be conducted to give you a
clear path of the boom's taxonomy
pyramid and no matter what the user's
initial experience with bio
bioinformatics is omix logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets an
introduction to basic languages
basic coding languages like r and python
will also be given and beginning that
would help you begin a data analysis
project
we will also combine pre-recorded mentor
sessions online live qmna sessions and
self-guidance study material
including courses on the omixlogic learn
portal and example projects which will
include some practical assignments and
quizzes as well for an immersive
experience that has to be that has
proven to be effective and are
well-known and respected omics logic
programs
so the program will leverage our
top-rated online tutorials that i'll be
just taking you through using the portal
with smart tracking of activity and
curated data sets designed for a great
learning experience
communication plays a key role for your
activities in the program so please make
sure that all the participants of the
program have joined the sky group where
you can access the session recordings
learn about the associated resources to
be completed as a part of the session
get updated on supplementary material
and assignments you can also clarify
your questions or request a live q a
meet with the mentor for the same and
not only this but you will also get to
interact with our bioinformatics
community and grow your network
and we have a note for the participants
who have taken up the advanced
subscription level
as a part of the advanced subscription
level you are supposed to work on a
research project as soon as the program
training is over
so you are requested to fill out the
research proposal form
as soon as you have your research
question designed for the same
now what is that in the research
proposal form that is what i wanted to
highlight on so first of all you have to
mention your basic details and then you
have to mention the project title that
you would like to work on that you will
definitely come up with after removing
literature for the same then you have to
provide a project description
and then a project summary that should
include the background of the literature
review that you went through what your
research question is specifically
what are the objectives and how you want
to answer the research question like a
flow that you have analyzed after
reviewing the literature and then you
have to provide the link for raw data
now what is the link of the raw data
here it is definitely the protein
structure that you want to work with so
you have to give the link
to that particular protein structure or
molecule and then you give the
references
we will share this project proposal form
with you over an email as well i just
wanted to go through this proposal form
with you once so that you know what
you're expected to submit as soon as
your training is complete
all right so that were few points that i
wanted to discuss before we get started
with the session now let's quickly sign
up on the portal and make sure that we
have everything ready before we start
with the session and we have all things
done for the program
i'll quickly
share my google screen now
all right so those who have already
created an account for themselves on the
onyx logic lawn portal please put a yes
or one in the chat box so that we know
you are all set and those who have not
created an account yet please do so
we'll be giving you a few minutes here
so that you can create an account our
team is here and if you face any
technical issues we'll be able to assist
you
we'll pause here for a minute or two so
that you can uh
easily create your account and the ones
who have created the account please take
this time to update your profile
i'll give a quick
about how you can sign up on the onyx
logic learn portal if you are new to
this platform so the link is in the chat
box just click on the link it will
redirect you to the honestly portal you
simply click on the login button which
will give you some options uh to sign in
either you create some credentials for
yourself and put in your details which
includes your name your college or
institute and create an account that
ways or you simply use any one of your
social media accounts that could be
google facebook
later and sign up
that is create an account on the portal
i'll use one of my google accounts to do
so
please feel free to ask us any question
related to sign up for now if you are
trying to sign up i am not able to do so
we awaiting the responses in the chat so
that i know that we are all set to
proceed ahead
what about others have you set up your
profile
all right let me just also give a quick
demo for those who have created that
account yet uh so what's the next step
for them the next step for them is to
update their profile
so please make sure that you have an
updated profile picture your name should
be in title case and add a brief bio
about yourself that could include your
educational background or your research
and trust
an updated profile helps the mentor know
about your background first of all and
also we'll be monitoring monitoring your
progress and the back end for the
program on your profile section itself
so this is the place where we get to
know what you have been completing which
resources are you working on which
assignments have you submitted which
quizzes have you completed and also a
complete profile helps the recruiters
see your profiles and maybe give you
good nice offers so this is what a
complete profile could offer you where
you can see your activity you can see
your completed courses and also once a
course is completed you can easily
download your certificate and share your
achievements with the word
this is one thing that i wanted to share
that was about sign up and making sure
that you have a complete profile
the next thing is that each and every
uh step that you complete in your
coursework or
in assignment that you complete or quiz
that you complete your achievements will
be recorded on our achievement board and
we'll be able to monitor your progress
from here
and achieving the specific points that
are required for you to complete a good
number of courses and your program could
give a chance to you to appear on our
leaderboard so here is the leaderboard
link all these links would be
found in the important links section
that is towards the bottom of the portal
so here you can uh get a chance to
appear on a leaderboard as well with an
exceptionally great performance on the
on this logic learn portal and also you
will stand the chance here to view the
job listings that we are updating on our
portal that you can view based on your
skill sets and you will find the list
the link to the job listings as well
to uh
the job listings on the portal itself
towards the end
these are the links where it does not
mention
so that was all that i wanted to mention
now let's get started without any delay
and towards the end i'll be taking you
through the program page i'll be
discussing the schedule of this uh the
program including each and every session
and what we'll be covering and also in
showcase you the program page where you
will find all the recordings if you
happen to miss any one of them and where
you can also find the materials the
associated resources and the
supplementary material that you are
supposed to go through along with each
session so that i'll be taking up
towards the end and now i would like to
pass on this session to dr mohit so that
we can get started for today's session
topics
thank you
hello everyone am i on audible
yes sir you are audible and we can see
yourself
okay perfect
so um thank you everyone for joining
today's session and thank you sonalika
for describing the
program in detail and how we are going
to conduct and utilize some of the
resources that you showcased and also
making sure that everyone is logged in
so that we can also help uh they can
use
use the resources seamlessly so now uh
about the session um as we have we are
meeting for the first session
i would like to introduce myself and
it'll be great if you can also introduce
yourself in the chat and that would help
me also to make
go through this session in a systematic
way i mean we will be covering some of
the basic concepts today and i don't
want to go much into that if you already
know about it so that we can progress
towards the hands-on situation that we
also have planned for today's session
and we will discuss about what all we
will be doing throughout the program
which will include mostly working on
case studies and learning about the
tools and then practicing them and then
communicating with the mentors and
developing a research project towards
the end of the program so there are
a lot of opportunities that all of the
participants will be having and
depending on your time schedule and
depending on your
expertise we will be able to help you
out with that uh before uh we start
again please uh it'll be great if you
can introduce yourself like uh write
your uh educational background and if
you have uh if you have experience in
chem informatics or in
uh structural biology that would be also
good to know uh about myself uh
okay let me play the
presentation
so about myself uh my name is mohit
mazumdar and i am a bioinformatician by
education and since last 12 years i've
been practicing and applying
bioinformatics for research and now both
research and for collaborations and for
education so during my phd uh i was
working on several drug targets and key
protein
key proteins as i was associated with a
structural biology lab and
and that had led to several
opportunities
to actually work on new structures which
are not even published and then what are
the different ways to analyze those
structures what are this
how much they are talking about
about the function and what are the
different ways we can correlate
structure with function and then
probably uh design several uh strategies
uh around it so um
as i was telling you that uh in my phd i
was working with several key drug
targets and one of the objective was to
understand the site specific mechanism
so sometimes
the objective of doing a drug discovery
project or structural biology project or
understanding the chemi chemi
informatics that would be required to uh
give us
the desired result it is important to
understand
the specifics of the
very much detailed version of what you
can look at and what you can find in
literature in different databases and
then develop a model so that's that
would be the purpose of this uh this
entire entire program so uh
understanding the site specific
differences mechanisms comparisons and
i'm talking about three-dimensional
structures here and then developing
strategies to overcome challenges
specific to structure based drug
designing
and learning about how what would be the
next steps so what would be the next
steps for after the structure based drug
designing and
understanding where molecular dynamic
simulations and quantum mechanics all of
that are
applicable and where are the innovations
that are happening in the industry with
ai and the deep learning
uh but to give you a prospective this is
a chem informatics and biomedical drug
discovery program and uh we should be
able to
uh together visualize how all of this
would be because all of this will be a
visual experience so you'll be working
on three-dimensional structures and at
the same time you'll be working and
looking at
small molecules so let's start with this
slide which which shows the emerging
drugs so to understand that
i mean how the drugs actually look like
it's it's it's uh it's a slide basically
describing that that the
the uh fda's center for drug evaluation
and research which has approved 16 new
medicines uh for now and 15 noble drugs
were approved
in 2021 and 53 noble drugs were approved
in 2020 so uh in 2022 the potential new
drug targets are you can see that there
are big companies involved in this
uh you can see now what is astrazeneca
and then different types of molecules
which are like more target based so if
you can see that estrogenicus search for
treatment of er positive breast cancer
which is more specific to uh individual
mutations are also
also described in this in this uh
in this slide so
talking about malaria neutrogen on
malaria or the drug that biogen came up
with for autoimmune diseases and then
for bristol myers
the
ubiquitinase mechanism targeting that
and like it's new village ligase
modulation so these are target driven
drugs
and uh this is this is described with a
mechanism of action
and we can perhaps uh maybe understand
some of these case studies in the
program going forward that how drug
purposing is also uh drug repurposing is
also
uh one of the
ways we can um we can counter or we can
find solutions to some of these diseases
and today in this session we will be
using one of such case studies
which is a straightforward case
that
that we were looking at
so thank you for all of you for starting
to share about your background it's
really helpful to learn uh starting from
kritika i
[Music]
and mikhail with michaela and all of you
so it's thank you so much for sharing
about your educational background and uh
where where you are from i see that we
have a lot of a lot of students from our
participants from nigeria
and we have a lot of uh also
ongoing programs going in nigeria and
africa so good to see participants from
south africa
and india
and i'm hoping that we will be
able to help you uh help you with some
of the structural biology related uh
very structural biology related
uh ideas because in this program uh one
of the objective is to develop that idea
into a project and that's why sonalika
specifically uh discussed about that in
the beginning
and uh shared also the
project submission form
so please feel free to write about your
ideas maybe you don't have all the
components there but then you can
obviously connect with us on skype and
have those discussions and we will be
able to answer them not right away but
whenever we will be able to see them we
will be able to
be able to communicate in that sense so
when you're communicating on skype and
when you're communicating in other
places uh please be patient as we are
working uh all the time but we'll be
looking at those questions and we'll be
helping you out with
answers and then we have these sessions
planned as well along with that there
are recorded sessions and videos and all
of this so
i think we will be able to cover all of
that
uh
okay hello matter so um andrea and
cleveland and chaku so thank you again
and now about the context of the program
now we are moving towards the um towards
the actual session so in the context of
the program this is the learn program
page and uh we will be running this
program for at least three months which
is also one of the subscription levels
so to those who are subscribing for 3
months or 60 days or 2 months or 1 and a
half month 45 days and we will be able
to cover and cover those objectives
within the time frame
now about today's session so today's
session is uh focused on uh some of the
basic concepts that are really important
to start from the beginning and develop
an understanding and holistic
understanding of how structural biology
or computational structure biology is
being utilized by researchers and
utilized by industry so understanding
the molecular structure of biological
macromolecules because those are the
target structures then understanding
what are the technologies that are being
used right now to generate such
information and the technology could be
about uh the way we have evolved using
you know extra crystallography now cryo
em and all of that and then what are the
ways to uh to look at this what are the
primary secondary tertiary quaternary
and structural domains structural
motives protein subunits so many of them
are covered in basic textbooks and i
guess many of you are kind of aware
about all of this and perhaps anyone can
google some of these keywords and get a
better better understanding from the
search results by going through
wikipedia and all so our focus will not
be you know to go through the go through
these topics just like a traditional way
but what we will be doing is like we
will be working on some of these topics
uh to do some hands-on and uh understand
from a case study level but
again uh we for those who are from uh
from not from a structural biology
background have never heard of some of
these keywords we have uh put together
these lessons that will be helpful for
those who unders wants to understand for
example what is structural biology
structural biology is the study of how
biological molecules are built using a
variety of imaging techniques scientists
view molecules in three dimensions to
see how they are assembled how they
function how they interact so that has
helped researchers understand how the
thousands of different molecules in each
of our cells work together to keep us
healthy so structural studies have shown
how uh you know mutations or mishappens
molecule make a sick and as a result
this study had studies have prompted a
new treatments for many diseases so that
is one of the objectives uh molecules
what are molecules so molecules can be
uh grouped into two or three atoms set
together by a chemical bond so molecules
we will be discussing about rna
we discuss about dna proteins
carbohydrates sugar and lipids fat so
structural biologists as as a as
structural biologists these are very
particularly interest interest
gives a lot of interest because uh of
the nature of this to be protein and
then we are investigating uh these large
molecules made up of combination of rna
and protein and then rna protein
complexes so uh these proteins are
molecules that contribute
virtually to every activity in the body
they form air they form
fingernails they carry oxygen in the
blood allow muscles to grow and move and
mass more so
proteins are made of long strands of
small molecules called amino acids and
we will be looking at amino acids how
they look in three dimension uh and what
are the way they move and what are the
different side chains and all of that so
uh there are 20 amino acids found in
nature each mi each protein contains a
unique combination of few dozens of many
thousands of amino acids so some
proteins consist of multiple amino acid
strands that are
wound together
so one of the important aspects of
discussing about all of this is also uh
like the shape
uh when we are discussing about the
shape uh we are discussing about the
three-dimensional or the tertiary
structure and we are talking about the
strand twist bends and folds so
then we are discussing about how to
understand uh the way protein folds
so we in this context uh would also be
discussing about the
new ai driven uh ai guided deep mind
alpha fold and uh we'll discuss that how
protein folding has
has been
almost
now much more easier than to do this
before so all of this i mean now anyone
can do this and
students from high school students
without a background of biology
and
specific computational biology will be
able to learn and go through this
training and learn how to apply this and
how to use this
so uh we have couple of lessons that
describes uh the computational structure
biology that we will be covering in this
session and the next session
introduction to chem informatics where
we will be discussing about the
chemical world
so um the
different aspects of proteins like we
will be discussing about these different
case studies which are about different
proteins so different proteins have
different functions and their shapes or
specific functions help cell hold their
shapes and move and movement and all of
that uh there is a type of protein
called trans transporter proteins that
are embedded in the cells outer membrane
and form channels that are that helps in
vital uh movement of vital substances
such as sodium calcium that pass into or
out of the cell so
i mean in the context of drug discovery
uh in the context of drug discovery or
to develop new drugs so drugs typically
work by either blocking or supporting
the activity of specific proteins in the
body so uh we will be discussing an
approach called structure based drug
designing
west scientists usually make a template
for a protein use that blueprint to
create new medicines so that's the
mechanism in a layman's world but uh to
do this computationally we will be able
to do this in an instantly environment
where the the thought process will be to
mimic what is happening within the body
or within the system so computer model
would allow it that allows us like to
examine this in several ways and that's
why we were talking about you know
molecular dynamics simulations or we are
talking about molecular docking
simulations
so um
i mean there are several examples now uh
where people have determined this or
have gone into
different clinical stages and also come
up with a
drug
structure based drug and now knowledge
based as well so there's a lot of
information and there's so much
databases and now what we've been able
to do is connect that information
uh
uh fill up those uh connect those dots
fill up those blanks and that utilizes
you know deep learning a lot of deep
learning and a lot of structure based on
knowledge based drug discovery so all of
this
could be learned through the coursework
that we've been discussing this is a
short session so one of the objective
would be for you would be to understand
this in the context that where are these
resources and what we can do when before
we've made again so these are some of
the things that you can do on your own
and together with the help of mentors
we will be able to work on some of these
aspects now
um the first thing we need to do
to start going to get going is to
understand that where is this data
is available and
how to interpret this data so today we
will be
doing that so protein data bank archive
information about cd structures of
proteins nucleic acids and protein data
bank is a
free repository where we would be going
and doing some of our analysis
understanding where to find this
information how to interpret this
information so i was talking about the
three-dimensional shapes but in terms of
proteins you can see here in this image
different types of proteins and like
really all kinds of weird shapes and
like really i mean that kind of explains
the diversity in this uh in this area so
um i mean now what we want to know about
this how complex assemblies uh and this
understanding helps students and
researchers understand all aspects of
biomedicine and uh we will know about
application in biomedicine which is
quite evident but it has application in
agriculture
uh from protein synthesis to health and
diseases so the rcsb pdb uh builds upon
the data
by creating tools and resources for
research and education as well as
education in molecular biology
structured biology computational biology
and beyond and one of the things that we
will be discussing in this context is
uh about a case study uh that would be
on sas prove to
uh go with 19
uh so in one and a half year of the
world wh world health organization's
declaration within one and a half year
when uh like when who uh
declared that poke 19 is a pandemic
over 1000 structures of sars proof to
biomolecules have been deposited in the
protein data bank uh it's a rare uh to
obtain such a it's very rare to obtain
such a snapshot of intense effort in
structural biology
and
that happened and still there are so
many structures coming up uh especially
with cryo em now and uh and then there
are other repositories so here in the
image you're seeing protein data bank
you're seeing uh other repositories
which are maintained by embl ebi
so
um
in that context it's it's important to
understand where to find the
information where to find these sort of
information which is already available
which can actually help you save a lot
of days in your research it will
actually help you uh explain this to
someone else in a in a very simplified
way so that you can go to the next level
so that's why
that's the objective of the session and
unity brought for example uh if you just
search in uniprop uh is is one of the
world's leading high quality uh
comprehensive and freely resource
freely accessible resource
of protein sequences and functional
information so similarly after these are
the data databases and repositories
which are maintained by
which are maintained by empl so we will
be looking at the repositories that are
maintained by ncbi uh
ncbi portal as well but in today's
session uh we will be looking at some of
these repositories so uh about pdb uh e
is again the founding member of
the
worldwide
protein data bank wwpdp which collects
and organizes and disseminates this data
for bio biological micro molecular
structures so there's a lot of
information and structures that could be
downloaded from here and understand the
the chemistry some of the chemistry how
it is connected with it so embl has also
developed the and integrated with alpha
fold so alpha fold is a ai system
developed by deep mine uh that predicts
our proteins uh 3d structure
promise amino acid sequence
uh it regularly achieves accuracy uh
competitive with the experimental
structure
so i have been you know
talking about this alpha fold and in
many of my webinars we have
gone through the
way alpha fault came up and
also
we have gone through
um
one of the video uh which explains alpha
four so just let me ask you this
question like how many of you know about
alpha fold and are you interested to
look at the video of how this came up or
we
would you want to skip that part so can
you tell me in the chat please so do you
know about how much you know about alpha
4 you're interested in the video or
let's skip that so as i was telling you
that alpha fold is a ai system developed
by deep mind and it predicts protein
structures three structures from
sequences so deep mind uh
deepmind and embl uh european biomedic
bioinformatics institute ebi has
partnered to create an alpha food
database so uh the alpha four database
uh which is what i'm showing you on the
slide uh is to make these predictions
freely available to the scientific
community
so
and um since it has been an year uh that
in the cast 14 they did this and then
it has been a year so
since then they have done
they have done 200 200 million
predictions so they have done 200
million predictions which is available
on this website that is what i'm showing
you on the screen
and uh we will be sharing the links
over the email i think uh does just uh
told you about that but after the se
after the session there will be an email
that will
that will have all this information that
we are covering and then you will also
get the
video recording so that's another way
so right so as i was saying that the
latest uh alpha alpha this database
contains 200 million protein structures
and provide a broad coverage of uniprot
uh where you will be able to see protein
sequences as well as the notation so
it's a great place to you know do what
it's a great place to come up with
research proposals and problems and
finding those proposals and problems so
uh you can individually download that in
the context of human proteome and 47
other key organisms so you can target
organism wise look at the structures
predicted structures and then
hypothesize from there so it's it's it's
very becoming much and much easier it's
just that one one has to look at it and
and then start digging and then
develop a proposal
uh that's
what i will be expecting from some of
you uh before we meet again so please i
mean go through these resources and
then look at some of the uh
some of the interest interested protein
structures interested proteins or
interested organisms
that you would want to
forgo further investigate further and
then we would be able to uh
we would be able to
do this so let's move to the next uh
video i think you said that you are
interested in the video so in the next
session when we have the alpha fold lots
of the plan so these are some of the
links uh github links google collab
notebooks that we will be going through
so today's session we are not doing
google
uh but we will be having an basics uh
basic introduction to google collab and
then we will run some of the collab
notebooks and run some predictions uh
using python google collab
uh and we'll be sharing these things
with you
now
this video i can play this
just a second
and let me know in the chat if it is
audible
we've discovered more about the world
than any other civilization before us
but we have been stuck on this one
problem how do proteins fold up
how do proteins go from a string of
amino acids to a compact shape that acts
as a machine and drives life
when you find out about proteins it is
very exciting you could think of them as
little biological nano machines they are
essentially the fundamental building
blocks that power everything living on
this planet
if we can reliably predict protein
structures using ai that could change
the way we understand the natural world
[Music]
protein folding is one of these holy
grail type problems in biology we've
always hypothesized that ai should be
helpful to make these kinds of big
scientific breakthroughs more quickly
and then i'll probably be looking at
little turnings that might make a
difference you should be creating some
disagreement at a background
we've been working on our system alpha
fold really hard now for over two years
rather than having to do paint staking
experiments in the future biologists
might be able to instead rely on ai
methods to directly predict structures
quickly and efficiently generally
speaking biologists tend to be quite
skeptical of computational work and i
think that skepticism is healthy and i
respect it but i feel very excited about
what alpha folk can achieve
is when we we say
look deep minded procedures holding this
is how good we are and maybe it's better
than everybody else maybe it isn't we
decided to enter casper competition
because it represented the olympics of
protein folding
we started to try and speed up the
solution to the protein folding problem
when we started cass in 1994 i certainly
was naive about how hard this was going
to be it was very cumbersome to do that
because it took a long time let's see
what we're doing still to prove
typically a hundred different groups
from around the world participate in
casp and we take a set of 100 proteins
and we ask the groups to send us what
they think the structures look like we
can reach 57.9 gdp
on cast 12 ground truth
casp has the metric on which you will be
scored which is this gdt metric
on a scale of 0 to 100 you'd expect a
gdt over 90 to be a solution to the
problem
if we do achieve this this has
incredible medical relevance the
implications are immense
from
how diseases progress
how you can discover new drugs
it's endless i wanted to make a really
simple system and the results have been
surprisingly good the team got some
results with a new technique not only is
it more accurate but it's much faster
than the old system i think we'll uh
substantially exceed what we're doing
right now
game changer i think
in casp 13 something very significant
had happened for the first time we saw
the effective application of artificial
intelligence we've advanced the state of
the art in the field so that's fantastic
but we still have a long way to go
before we've solved it the shapes were
now approximately correct for many of
the proteins but the details exactly
where each atom sits which is really
what we would call a solution we're not
yet there
it doesn't help if you have the tallest
ladder when you're going to the moon
we hit a little bit of a brick wall um
since we won casp then
it was back to the drawing board and
like what are our new ideas um
and then it's taking a little while i
would say for them to get back to where
they were but with the new ideas
and then now i think we're seeing the
benefits of the new ideas they can go
further right so
that's a really important moment i've
seen that moment so many times now but i
know what that means now and i know this
is the time now to press we need to
double down and go as fast as possible
from here i think we've got no time to
lose
so the intention is to enter casp again
casp is deeply stressful there's
something weird going on with um the
learning because it is learning
something that's correlated with gdt but
it's not calibrated i feel slightly
uncomfortable we should be learning this
you know in the blink of an eye the
technology advancing outside deep mind
is also doing incredible work there's
always the possibility another team has
come somewhere out left field that we
don't even know about someone asked me
well should we panic now of course we
should have been panicking before it
does seem to do better but still doesn't
do quite as well as the best model um so
it looks like there's room for
improvement there's always a risk that
you've missed something and that's why
blind assessments like casper so
important to validate whether our
results are real obviously i'm excited
to see how cast 14 goes my expectation
is we go heads down and focus like the
full goal which solve the whole problem
the prime minister has announced the
most drastic limits to our lives that
the uk has ever seen in living memory
people a very simple instruction you
must stay at home
we were prepared for cask start on april
15th because that's when it was
originally scheduled to start and it's
been delayed by a month due to
coronavirus i really miss everyone i
struggled a little bit just kind of
getting into a routine especially
with my wife she came down with the
virus i mean luckily it didn't turn out
too serious cusp started on monday can i
just check this diagram you've got here
john this one where we ask ground truth
is this one we've done badly on we're
actually quite good on this region if
you imagine that we hadn't have said it
came around this way but had to put it
down instead yeah one of the hardest
proteins we've gotten in casp thus far
is a source cove ii protein uh called
orphan or eight is a coronavirus protein
we tried really hard to improve our
projection like really really hard
probably the most time that we've ever
spent on a single target so we're about
two-thirds of the way through casper and
we've gotten three answers back we now
have a ground truth for all eight which
is one of the grown virus proteins
and it turns out we did really well in
predicting that
amazing job everyone the whole team it's
been an incredible effort
here what we saw in cast 14 was a group
delivering
atomic accuracy off the bat essentially
solving what in our world is two
problems how do you
look to find the right solution and then
how do you recognize you've got the
right solution when you're there all
right are we mostly here
i'm going to read an email
uh i got this from john malt
i'll just read it says john as i expect
you know
your group has performed amazingly well
in
both relative to other groups and an
absolute model accuracy
congratulations on this work it is
really outstanding
fold represents a huge leap forward that
i hope will really accelerate drug
discovery and help us to better
understand disease it's pretty
mind-blowing you know these results were
for me having worked on this problem so
long after many many stops and starts
and will this ever get there suddenly
this is a solution we solve the problem
this gives you such excitement about the
way science works about how you can
never see exactly or even approximately
what's going to happen next there are
always these surprises and that really
as a scientist is what keeps you going
what's the going to be the next surprise
[Music]
all right and that was about the
the alpha fold discovery
and the team and how they able to
work
out and come up with this algorithm
now uh in context of how we are going to
use it it is a different story
altogether so
what we would be trying is there are
some obviously this is a huge leap and
has helped us in finding some of the
those structures
where we have the information before but
uh where there is no information when
the way there is no experimental
structures available then if there's a
unique
uh unique uh motif or protein that is
something that is still not answered or
answered by the ai based
models so some of the limitations that
would be answered through experimental
techniques and we have those techniques
which are evolving also at the same pace
and with
the new structures and everything i
think this is going to be um
getting better and better uh only uh
another the last database today that we
are discussing about is the
chem embl so chemi mbl is another now we
are discussing from discovery now to
chemistry uh so chemistry km embl is a
manually curated database of biologic
bioactive molecules that has drug like
properties uh it brings together
chemistry uh bioactivity genomic data as
well to aid the translation of genome
genetic information into uh these
effective new drugs so cam mbl is a
database again which has two two
dimensional structures calculated
properties such as log b molecular
weight and then
lipinski parameters and abstracted
bioactivities such as binding constant
pharmacology and data so this data is
abstracted and curated uh from either
publications like uh primary scientific
literature and covers fractions of these
uh
and helps us in you know structure
activity relationships and discovery of
modern drugs so uh as we have been
discussing and discussed so many uh
these not so many at least uh four or
five of these uh databases uh it'll be
really great uh if you can uh maybe
browse uh some of them as we will be
also sharing with you the links and all
uh after the session so please after the
between the sessions please go through
this and
have the questions that you can ask us
related to them now we will be moving
towards the case study and we discussed
about coronavirus and uh the sas group
two so we'll take scope two as a case
study so the uh
the entire all of the sas group 2
pandemic has also shown a light on many
diverse contribution of this in silicon
structural biology work so initially
structural prediction work uh we used to
you we had used in that time modulus ice
i tester and alpha fold and this deep
mind
all of that but one of the key
challenges now is to understand that you
heard of the way some of these proteins
replicate and the the way they they
create these mutations and there are
several copies so understanding the
the way
the mutations actually these mutations
can
disrupt or become more lethal so we have
a case study planned on that not in the
first session obviously
towards the uh
towards
the second or third session where we
will be we'll be able to
look at the specific types of uh these
variants and the structures because many
of the structures have now reported and
uh at a very good resolution so we can
do that case study uh where we can
compare the variations that you could
see in different types of these variants
uh where there are different mutations
and different locations so
that is the case study that we have
planned
uh but in uh addition like the uh
if you look at these structures uh all
of this uh started with the spike uh
protein and uh
which is at the surface of the corona
virus so uh
these spikes and giving them their
distinctive ground like appearance in
electron micrographs that's the reason
they're called
the they're called spike so the spike
initiation initiates the process of
infection and then binding to the
receptors and then fusing with the cell
membrane to release the
viral genome inside and many of you
might be our virologist and have a
better understanding but from a
structural point of view what i'm trying
to describe here is that many other
enveloped viruses such as uh similar to
spike proteins uh to infer use the
similar mechanism to infect cells that
has been known as some
for example uh influenza
and the envelope glycoproteins of hiv
one and ebola as well so this uh
the spike protein is com is composed of
three identical chains so we are talking
about three chains a b and c chains and
uh
and then together they form a complex uh
with a small domain inside the virus a
membrane spa spanning segment and a
large electro domain that extends uh the
uh spike protein uh into different types
of like it it is very flexible to move
in that manner so in this in this
in this uh slide uh we uh i'm trying to
explain the same thing that
when you look at and look at these
structures and recent structures have
revealed that the spike of suscope 2
[Music]
are kind of flexible so in this in the
structures the receptor binding domains
are seen in different conformation
now uh about confirmation is again one
of the limitation with the same protein
you will find different conformations so
how do you understand that what would be
the best confirmation to target or what
is the actual or the average
confirmation and all of that so
those are some of the questions that
could be answered when you go through
and learn from uh different aspects
about uh molecular dynamics simulations
averaging structures and understanding
the movement but uh actually these
different confirmations actually helped
us a lot with all of this the extended
confirmation is needed to bind the
receptor
and
and
and the flexibility is a great advantage
actually to the virus because the
researchers hypothesized that the recent
variants are violent because the
receptor binding documents are
particularly flexible uh where as the
more widespread coronary viruses that
causes the common cold uh which are less
flexible so these are some of the
examples that we should be able to take
a look at and uh
let's do that in the context of
visualization
so this last uh last uh part of the
session is doing some hands-on using
molecular visualization so that's as we
have shared that with you so 6m17 and
6vsb are the four digit later code that
are that you can find on pdb so let's
click on some of these links
and uh open this in a browser and let me
know if you can see if you can see my
browser or not
so this is a link that where we have
opened a pdp file and
then in the context of visualization we
are going to use pymol
so pymol is a strong molecular
visualization software
and in this slide you will be able to
see that i have put together a lot of
links from uh like how you can install
pineapple so can you tell me like is it
installed in your system any of you like
uh do you know like have you installed
primal ever or is it like uh something
that uh
that
you
you can do
so
all right so many of you are saying yes
you have you have it installed and uh
for those who haven't who haven't
or hasn't uh i'll share this uh these
links in the chat perhaps that would be
a quick way we will be sharing this
in an email
but
but let me share all these links
uh in the chat
so those who have not uh
installed
can utilize and uh one of the thing is
that pymol is a propriety software
by scrotinger
but again there are academic versions
educational versions available they are
little tricky to install but you'll find
one of them in the link
so if you don't have the full version or
if you have the demo version and if you
use it for academic uh purposes you can
have the full version and all the
capabilities uh exploring some of these
links and i think that we will not do in
the session but if you have issues
please feel free to write that in the
chat group
and we will be able to help you
now uh if you have installed it the next
step is to use it and uh before using it
let's understand a little bit about the
interface of pymol
so
uh the interface uh before understanding
about the interface uh it would be good
to understand that
what are the basics like how do we
visualize files and what is there in the
pdb file so uh can you tell me like do
you know what is uh what is there in a
pdb file how the coordinates are
are stored or do you have any idea like
about the um
extra crystallography and all those
methods that generates these
experimental files because what i want
to describe discuss next is this text
file that we get from the experiments
like x-ray diffraction uh extra
crystallography or other techniques so
this is the file this is a text file so
when you're downloading uh uh
from pdb you kind of download a text
file and then you open it up on a in a
software that kind of projects these
coordinates in a three-dimensional space
does that make sense to all of you
all right um so that's the whole idea
that from uh from a text file the
software generates the coordinates and
uh and put it in a three-dimensional
space and i'm discussing this uh because
it's important to understand and and if
you understand this you will be able to
actually do some modifications on your
own just through the structural
visualization so what we want to
understand in this image that is on the
on the
left hand side of uh the screen
um is uh the pdb file yeah we can do it
uh
so let's do this let's do this
practically i'll i'll stop uh the
uh i'll go we'll go to that website and
let's let's do this there
so on the in the context of uh
this file
and this is uh
uh a structure that i've been describing
in the presentation it's a membrane
protein and it's a viral protein and uh
this is uh there's this information that
this is generated through cryo-em
structure cryo-em technology and this is
the resolution
now uh there are other information
there's a associated publication
published in science so you can check
the article here and understand more
about it that would be the best way to
understand about the structure
and then there are different information
so this is the complete a chain and
and d and c chain so we have the
sequence is 654
amino acid long and this is one of the
visuals of the structure and then going
down you will find more information
about different clusters and then you
can zoom in and look at these individual
residues compare these different uh
sequence clusters which are similar to
this protein and then the second
molecule so they this is like not just
one molecule there are two molecules so
angiotensin covering enzyme two so a
h2 receptor is also there so you will be
able to see the protein protein uh
complex in this molecule now
similarly there is a third molecule uh
the spike protein s1 so this information
is right here like the number of
molecules that are that are there in the
three-dimensional structure
co-crystallized there are so many
co-crystallized structures some of them
are some of them are part of the
experimental structure some of them are
artificial artifacts from the
from the solution so you have to
understand that which are the important
part and which they are not and these
sort of information is available right
here that's the way to read through this
information here that once you go to
this page read about this information
get that understanding and there are
here tabs also so 3d 3d view
and then annotation so we can go through
all of this this will take a while but
uh let's uh let's download this
structure first and then we will do a
visualization uh on primal and the next
time then when we meet uh we will be
able to uh maybe discuss all of this and
answer the questions that you haven't
feed you'll be able to ask those
questions so you will see that there are
different ways that you can directly
visualize right here in the on the
browser so you don't even need to have
primal for that
primol is for those uh maybe
where you're predicting and you're
modifying so it's great to have primal
capabilities generate high resolution
structures but here also these
capabilities are there you can look at
active sites you can look at different
sites you can click and understand the
interaction also which is a great
interface that pdb is now providing
within this uh within this uh portal
so
i i i wish that i hope that you all are
going to utilize some of these links and
i'll put it in the chat especially this
one that we are looking at so that you
all can look at it and
we can maybe do it together
so now uh let's download the structure
so while downloading these files
you'll find different uh file formats
that are there
now pdb format uh there is uh this
mmcif format so we
we can't discuss about these formats but
let's look at some of the uh one of
these formats
so i've downloaded this file
and
i can open it in a
in a text
editor so let me open this file
in a text editor
so you can use notepad notepad plus plus
wordpad any of these text editors to
open a pdb file that you have downloaded
now so using the link as you saw that i
easily downloaded that file and this is
how it looks like this is the structure
file this is the maybe a receptor file
this is how it looks it has lot of
remarks from the top towards
going towards the end and these remarks
are not read by the software but they
explains
they explain the characteristics of this
molecule or the structural factors
and some of the chains some of the
some of the interactions as well as
these sort of information so there's a
lot of information in this these gifts
just to tell you in in a
in a nutshell so header title author
records provide information about the
researchers who define the structure
numerous types of records are available
to provide other type of information
remark record provides you know
contains uh
free form annotation and then seek
secret uh that sequence uh rests records
gives the sequence of these three
peptide chains like abc d and all atom
records now what is important here is
the atom records from here this is the
important section this is the actual
file this is the actual structural file
so this is uh atom
this this atom uh
describes the
coordinate of the atom that is the part
of the protein for example the first
atom line describes the
alpha and atom so this is the nitrogen
at the alpha position
of the of the first residue of the
peptide chain a
i hope that this is kind of clear when
we will look at it in a
three-dimensional three-dimensional
visualization as well but uh that is how
it is so it is a valine
uh and the residue is valine and the
first three floating points this is x y
z this is x coordinate this is y
coordinate that's this is z coordinate
so x y z will be uh
will be transposed or will be plotted in
a three-dimensional software called
primal now um
i think this is clear and this is kind
of i explained it in much more depth the
next three columns are occupancy
temperature factor and the element name
respectively
then
we you will find towards the
um towards the end
these there are different chains like
i'm scrolling and i hope all of you are
able to see this
so this is a chain as as we know that
this is a big protein
uh then there is b chain you see that a
has changed to b now now this is b chain
so another subunit
and then there will be other chains also
each chain
and c chain as we were reading the
molecule their d chain
and then after the atoms i just wanted
to show heteroatoms these are the
heteroatoms now the ligands are usually
heteroatoms so
here you will find these nag which is
like a
crystallized i think uh these nags are
present and these are uh sorry not
crystallized like there are some
conditions
for this in the solution
and then they are there and then there
is water molecule and there is zinc also
so here towards the end you will find
zinc water molecules and all of that so
each chain had some water molecules that
have been traced and put together here
so this is how you read the pdb file now
you can manually actually extract some
of this information and paste it in a
new file and create dot pdb so you can
simply like if you want to extract the f
uh like the
f chain you just cut it like properly
and paste it in a same format and save
it like and rename it like f chain dot
pdb so that way you can manipulate this
pdb file you can take some of the
segments and open it and do those
exercises and those will be the
assignments for
the for today's session to manipulate my
pdb file and to do this do this on your
own
now uh the next thing we are going to
try is pymol now i have installed primal
on my system now i'll open pymol
by this command by mall
and this uh this
ampersand sign is actually a sign so
that lets me let me
um use the
use the
[Music]
console
now that's not important so yeah prime
all that is what we would be interested
in so we have open time all and we have
downloaded a structure
now let's open that structure in primal
and let's look at it uh and understand
what are the different ways we can
visualize it so now i have opened it in
pi mall and uh i'm rotating it using my
uh key
mouse pad tracking pad
now let's
let's
uh yeah i think it's visible to all of
you now here there are a few commands a
s h l c
so
a stands for action
and there are two tabs here all
and
this one so you can actually load
multiple structures and in the next
session we will be discussing about
structural alignment structural
comparison and there is a
workshop also coming up on alpha fold
and doing all of this so i hope that
as many of you would join the program
will be coming and participating on all
of those events
now looking at the structure now you can
zoom in as much as you want and you can
dive and look into each molecule so here
i have highlighted just i just selected
clicked here and there's this one
uh one atom which you just selected now
you can see that there are dots but it
is not showing in the presentation
because the presentation that we are
looking at is the cartoon presentation
now there are different types of
presentations visual like visual
presentations that we will be looking at
that will be exploring but this is a
cartoon presentation
now
to look at the side chain you need a
stick presentation this is a stick
presentation so this is the nag molecule
which is plotted all over here which is
uh which is you can see all over the
place molecule but that i have clicked
on an amino acid
which has a ring as it seems now i want
to see what is this amino acid so what i
will do i'll go to the select because i
have selected it there's a new tab that
has come up which says scle which is
select this is selected now whatever
i'll do will change
will make change to only this area so
this is the select and i'll do what i'll
try to show stick
as i was telling you this could be seen
in a stick representation now you can
see it's a stick representation and you
can look at the residue you can
take a look at the residue now
this is important in the context that if
you want to know about that
if there is a mutation and you have
figured out that you know that there's
this mutation
so you want to see what is the effect of
the mutation and
you can check out that by looking at the
recidu and then
then selecting that residue like it is
selected and in action
i'll use this function called modify
around four ranks strong so i wanted to
see that
where this residue is interacting with
is is it interacting with any other uh
molly uh other interum intramolecular
interactions within the protein so let's
look at that because if we want to
change this if we want to mutate it
obviously obviously some of these
interactions would be lost
so
as i did that what i did is that i went
in action modify around four angstrom so
i checked what are the interaction
around four angstrom now i have other
residues also getting highlighted or you
know there are these selections
selection has expanded to other
molecules which means that there are
other molecules that are there
interacting now i can also manipulate
the structure and mutate it
this is what let's take a look at what
is this uh what is this uh side chain
so to name it there is this
there is this
tab that says label so this is label
here you can also written action is
returned show is written hide is written
so you can show something you can hide
the same thing this is label it's
written and then there is color you can
change the color to different colors of
your liking or to highlight it basically
now i have selected this
now i want to mutate it but before that
i need to know which atom is it but this
is tyrosine
you know this is tyrosine because you
can see here when i selected this
console is also getting up updated and
uh it's
telling me that this is a beach in
tyrosine uh at 641 position but we can
label it and she'll see it in here so we
label it it's it's showing that now in
the screen you can see it's so showing
tyr 641 now i want to change the stylus
into alanine how would i do that how can
i do that in pymal itself so there is
this plug-in uh our wizard there is this
mutagenesis that you can do here right
in right in here
right it comes up here
now i have selected this one and uh mike
i want to change this mutation i want to
bring a mutation in the structure
by changing tyrosine to allergening now
what what do i want to change it into
alanine so i'll put ala
ala
and i'll apply
so i've changed mutate to lnn and these
are some of the
other
other options that i can change
so i'll apply
[Music]
it's asking me to pick a studio so
that's picker residue
um
all right
so let's try this again
it's asking me to select a rotamer
okay so i think there is the library
file for rotomers that we have to put in
here but there is this
mutation i think this now has changed
into alanine so the side chain has gone
but uh i think with the rotary library
it will uh it will be like uh give us
probabilities of this mutation so now
this mutation is changed into alanine so
this is one of the way i was just
showing all of you to work on these
protein structures
and do some manipulation using primal
now what we did is that we downloaded a
structure we played around with it and
we learned about some of these things
uh now uh for the assignment uh for the
students or participants of the program
we'll be sharing some of these protein
ids and ask you to prepare a report uh
where you have done some of this work or
we can discuss uh any of your interest
uh for what we have covered in this
session uh now uh as we are discussing
we were discussing we learned about
prime mall we learned about pdb we
learned about different databases
and we also learned about how can we do
some of these manipulations now we can
go much much depth of these and we will
be using these tools throughout the
program this is just an overview
so that many of you get started with
these things and develop these expertise
um
throughout the program with the help of
the mentors now going back to the
presentation
so in primal uh what we have done is
we have done the installation and then
we have done some basic analysis
then another visualization software that
is there is chimera
and in the next session we will look at
chimera and we will look at some of the
capabilities of chimera
and where
which is utilized for similarly we will
do mutagenesis and we will do some rmsd
calculations where we will compare two
structures and see how much they are
different
and uh then we have these sessions
coming up introduction to chem
informatics
um in the next session then we have
chemistry and protein databases many of
which we have covered but we will go in
more depth these are the some recorded
sessions also
and then we have the protein structure
prediction some of those case studies
like uh talking experiments set up what
are the different as we were discussing
more though the more we are being able
to mimic it the more high probability of
this to be accurate and then the drug
repurposing case study that uh we were
uh discussing will be discussed as well
and then the advancements of uh
transformation using gpu computing and
deep learning and uh different uh
molecular generation using deep learning
so these are some of the things that we
have it uh put together and before uh i
pass it on to sonalika to discuss about
uh the other aspects i would request you
to join linkedin this group uh this is a
group where uh this has grown now more
to more than 20 000 2000 people so here
we frequently post about the job
opportunities and all of that and uh
in the omics logistic group on uh on
facebook we also do the same so if
you're on facebook linkedin please join
these groups and then uh you will be lo
you'll be able to find job opportunities
there as well as on the learn oh my
logic portal so that's uh that's what i
wanted to cover in today's session and
uh i'll be happy to take the questions
that are there in the chat if uh if uh
spinalika or you can you can let me know
about those questions
and in the meantime um it was great
meeting you for all for the first
session i hope that this this was
something that was helpful and you learn
something new and we will try to make
this more and more interesting
throughout the program thank you so much
so we have a question by mckenna she is
asking what is the purpose of seeing the
activation energy while talking
what is the purpose of seeing what
sorry can you repeat this is the purpose
of seeing the
so what is the purpose of
seeing the activation energy while
docking
so activation
energy
i mean are we talking about the energy
minima and maxima like sometimes
molecules are in different energy states
but uh what we do usually in our
calculations is that
what we do is uh we kind of do energy
minimization so energy minimization what
it does is that it puts the structure in
a
global low energy state and that is like
that is said to be more close to the
negative protein
and that uh
that process of you know
doing energy minimization there's
steepest descent and conjugate gradient
these are the algorithms and uh there
are different um
softwares where we can achieve this
molecular minimization energy
minimization
and that helps us to get to low
potential energies
and uh
negative delta g so the
the changes you can see is that when you
when you look at delta delta g you
you'll be able to look at you'll be see
that there is high very high delta g
and then um then when you run energy
minimization you will be able to see
that the delta g has
changed and it's more now stable and
what it hap what happens actually is
that the atoms have they their location
and all of that they are just like
changed
based on to the most uh acceptable
confirmation that's all the software the
algorithm works but um yeah but that's
that's that's i hope that answers your
question
hello so can you hear me now
yeah yeah
yes sir so as a question by meeting mato
she is asking is alpha pole server
better than already available protein
structure prediction servers like eye
dancer and modeler
i think it's good it has such a good
great question but it is it actually
changes from study to study so some
proteins i mean i have done alpha fold
and i will not say that it predicts
everything like
like dream or like like like it says it
it does
because there are other challenges also
but yeah i mean i tested and models are
equally uh equally good
so it's good to have like maybe
comparative study while you go for a
structure prediction do like all of them
and see
uh and try to look at the statistics and
decide
thank you sir i hope that answers your
question nikki
and we have some questions regarding
assignments and also the session
recording i would uh be able to answer
those questions uh just in a while by
taking you through this program page
so if you have any technical questions
for dr mohit in the meantime you can
definitely put in the chat box and here
is the question by hershel
he is asking what would be a better
choice of force field and energy
minimization combination
yeah i mean i i like the force field
that has that scrodinger has developed
it is it is nice the amber force filled
the charm force field i think all of
them are good like all of the ones that
have been published and like thousands
and thousands of citations have already
happened for those
so you want to take
for for for predictions and dynamics and
all of that i i mean it's advisable to
use something which is validated over
and over
and
i mean that's my recommendation
right so thank you all right so now
going back to the program page
[Music]
uh i have shared the link of the chem
informatics program page in the chat box
this page is very important for all
those who have
joined the program for you to
uh go through the schedule keep a track
on what schedules uh what sessions do we
have scheduled on which particular dates
what are the associated resources and we
will also post the recordings of the
mental guided sessions here on the
program page itself so it's very
important for you to keep a track on
this program page for the entire
duration of your enrollment
all right so today we had the first
session those who are asking about the
recording of the session the recording
of the session will be updated on the
program page in an ro2 just when the
processing of the recording is complete
we'll we uploaded you can then access
the recording the program page can be
accessed by the program participants so
if you will have a badge on your profile
named as ken informatics for biomedical
drug discovery if you click on that
badge on your profile you will be
redirected to this program page i'll
just show it to you shortly or you can
directly access the page with the link
that i've shared in the chat i'll also
share this link by an email so will have
this link with you where you can access
the recordings look what the resources
are that you have to follow and find the
links of the supplementary material as
well
so uh here we have the session schedule
that i was talking about today we had
the first session the next session is
scheduled for august 25th so we'll be
having sessions for this program on
every monday and every thursday all
right uh to uh today the first session
was an exceptional case where it is
scheduled for tuesday because we already
had some pre-shooting sessions scheduled
for yesterday
but otherwise you will have these
sessions on mondays and thursdays to
keep a track of these sessions that's
what i'm telling you
then we have the third session on
chemical and protein databases on august
29th we have mentioned the topics here i
won't be going into much depth of each
and every topic for the sessions that we
would cover otherwise it will take a
long time
then we have the fourth session on
target structure prediction on september
1st target identification virtual
screening will cover on september 5th
practical experience and docking we'll
have a hands-on session for this on
september 8th and and on september 12th
we'll have the session on data science
and ai and healthcare and we practice
the our collab notebook for the same on
september 13 we have a workshop on alpha
phone a two hour long workshop where we
are going to have a practical hands-on
iphone phone all right and this is what
it is mentioned in the program as well
this is a two-hour workshop specifically
on september 15th we have the next
session on recent advances in drug
discovery this this session will be
taken up by an industry academy export
and then you have the next session on ai
and molecular drug discovery on
september 19th the next session will is
scheduled for september 22nd on advanced
chem informatics
and then towards the end we'll be
discussing about how you can design a
chemi informatics research project and
get started all together and finally
discuss some case study examples of
successful and failed drug development
by industry experts who were involved in
these successful and failed drug
development processes
all right so that is what is the
schedule of this program you can find it
on the program page and
today was the first session and we
invited also the participants who were
entrusted to enroll for the program as
they wanted to get some insights how the
session would be conducted today was a
much introductory session because we
wanted to get you all started and
introduce you to all the resources so
that you don't skip any one of these
please make sure that you join the skype
group because that is the way we can
stay connected every time
yes mail is also a very good option
where you can mail us on support at the
refine dot bio and connect with us for
any query but joining skype will also
keep on updating you about the sessions
recordings resources supplementary
material that we share and also i have a
chat with the mentor regarding the
questions that you might have or ask for
a
uh live zoom meeting to clarify your
questions all right so it would be very
helpful please try to download skype if
you're not there on skype create an
account we'll share the link with you
please join the community
all right
now for those who have not yet joined
the program and were here just to
get some insights on how the program
will be conducted and what the structure
of the program is but wish to continue
for the other sessions that they can
register themselves for the program uh
we are accepting registrations till
tomorrow and here we have three
different subscription types that you
can pick and enroll for it's uh
completely on you which particular level
type you want to pick i'll just quickly
explain what these includes so these
different subscription levels are
specifically or will give you access to
the program and the resources for
different numbers of days that is what
it means the 45 days one will give you
the access to the whole training program
a point to be mentioned the resources
and all of these three different subs uh
different subscription levels are the
same you'll get the same session
recordings and the uh supplementary
material as well
uh there is difference only in terms of
mental guidance and research work that
you uh do
or that you work on
so in the 45 days you will be able to
just complete the training program but
in 60 days as you will have some more
time you can meet the mentor
clarify your questions uh and also
discuss your research question that you
would like to work on design your
research hypothesis with the mentor in
these live sessions so it will be it
will include more of interactions with
the mentor where you can get all of this
done
and then the 90 days access that is the
advanced level uh subscription type you
will be able to
a research project along with the
training part as well
this is what i explained in the very
beginning of the session where i was
saying that the
participants who have taken up the 90
days of subscription you are required to
work on a research project so
uh the moment the training process is
complete the moment the training part is
complete all the sessions are covered
all the practical hands-on uh sessions
are completed and until then you will
have a good uh
idea about the concepts and you will
have some good hands-on practice as well
with these tools and software that we'll
be covering all right along with these
sessions what you can do is you can
start to literature review and at least
come up with the research question that
or maybe have some idea at least that
you would like to discuss with your
mentor
so uh you you can then i should do a
meeting with your mentor discuss your
idea what exactly you want to work on
and the mentor could uh help you frame
your question in the right manner or
modify a question it is required and
then you can get started to work on your
research project all right now what
would be the outcome of this research
project the very first thing is that you
will get to publish this project on the
honest logic non-portal itself where you
have this research publication that you
can share with your community or future
future recruiters or if you are a
student a graduate or a postgraduate
student and want to pursue higher
studies you could use this publication
for that as well you can present this
research work in any
good uh conference or symposiums in the
post presentation uh format all right
and definitely proceed ahead to publish
your research work in a repetitive
journal as well so that could be the
three different outcomes of uh working
on a research project
that was it that i wanted to discuss now
it's up to you which a particular
subscription type you want to pick it
really depends on how many days do you
have your availability for to work or uh
to learn a new skill set in book on a
project
all right and also we are offering great
scholarships uh to students and
researchers so you can reach out to
spash
on marketing advert or messaging.com and
she'll be able to help you out with uh
the scholarship uh opportunities she'll
be able to tell you how much scholarship
can you get on the program and uh also
uh sparsh if you can share scholarship
form so the participants can fill that
out we'll review your application and
we'll get back to you on the scholarship
uh that you can get for
joining the program so that was it now
we have some uh messages in the chat box
i would like to address them
did i have explained 60 days so i think
that is clear to you uh yes definitely
you will get the certificate so where do
you get the certificates for the uh
courses that you complete and for the
program that you complete so when you
will complete all the sessions on the
program page that i just showed you
after the completion of all these
sessions on the program page you will
get a certificate automatically on your
profile under the programs tab uh let me
look for a program that i have completed
so that i can show it to you here it is
uh there was a programmer introduction
to chemi informatics in the month of
april so i completed the sessions and
then you can move your certificate from
here and you can also download a
certificate directly from your profile
section
itself uh that was about certificates
and also along with each and every
session as i told you that you have to
complete some associated resources which
are the courses on the honest logic
learn portal itself so also for each and
every coursework that you complete you
are going to get the certificate that
you can download and share your
achievement on social media platforms
and uh sparsh has now shared the
scholarship form in the chat box thank
you sparsh uh those who are interested
to avail the scholarship please uh fill
out the form
and our team will get back to you after
uh reviewing your application
you were asking about how bioinformatics
can help you in your further studies
uh so for that uh it is first of all
very important as you are a biotech
student it's very important for you to
first of all know what the field of
bioinformatics is all about and identify
a research and trust all right so for
that you can go through the
bioinformatics coursework and bytes and
molecules on the unresolved learn portal
these two courses are free courses you
just need to create an account and
directly uh start with introduction to
bioinformatics and bytes and molecules
and these courses will give you a good
idea about what bioinformatics is all
about what is the role of bioinformatics
in healthcare
and uh what are the different
types of big data or mixed data that the
researchers are now dealing with or
working on all right so it's a very
short course work which will help you
give a help you get a good understanding
and then you have the next coursework
that is bytes and
bytes and molecules which will help you
understand the different types of comics
data of types i'll say our fields like
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
because you are a bsc biotech student i
know you are at a very early stage so
you can go through bytes and molecules
and get a good idea about what are these
different types of omnis data types and
what are the different specialization
tracks where these different common data
types have their applications and uh
what what type of data analysis is
involved and stuff so these are
introductory courseworks which are
definitely free of cost you can just
simply sign in and go through them and
identify your interest first like i
identify your interests which field uh
interests you the most and then you can
take it further
and learn more about all right so uh
today we are talking about structural
biology or chemi informatics so there is
a basic coursework that has been
recommended for you all to get started
uh for today's session that is protein
structure and function
so you can both go through this
particular lesson where we have tried to
explain what are the different types of
protein structures and uh
also
how the
uh structural biology was evolved all
together and what are the basic concepts
um in one
all right and uh
cynthia you will get to know about the
bioinformatics tools uh
for
uh coming to aria drug designing
definitely all came informatics serious
tools and databases uh throughout this
program today our idea was just to
introduce you uh to these different
tools and databases now we will take
each one of them and dig more get uh
like
we uh in the upcoming sessions we are
going to uh get more uh insights about
each and every tool and software or
database we'll explore these databases
extract these structures from these
databases and then work on them using
these different types of tools and
software's so today was just an
introductory session we did we wanted to
keep it light and not overwhelm you all
a lot with all these different types of
tools and databases and software's
working how do they actually work but
now we um try to
move from a big net level to an advanced
level slowly
all right i think those were the
questions that we had in the chat box to
address
and if there are any other questions you
can please put in the chat
uh oh cynthia uh about the 60 days part
uh so i said that you have three levels
45 60 and 90 days 60 days means two
months all right so you will be
completing the training part in one and
a half month and the other half month or
let's say 15 days that you will have
with you you can uh discuss with the
mentor uh your research uh hypothesis
all right
you will get to design a research
project okay
and uh to get started with it or to work
on it you definitely need an extension
so a 90 days of project
will
uh definitely
assure a publication of
a research publication but on a 60 days
if you take up a 60 day subscription
level it won't be easy for you because
in two months you can't complete the
training also and then work on a project
and get a complication that's
practically not feasible at all
so you will complete your training part
first and then do the literature review
come up with a question design your
hypothesis and then you start going on a
project so if you want to come up with a
publication a research publication
out of this program then maybe you can
take up the 90 days or the subscription
level and if you're seeking scholarship
this first can help you with that
uh so bridgette the first two courses
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules are free courses because
these are introductory courses and there
are many people who come from different
fields they might not be from
bioinformatics they might be from
biotech or microbiology or biochemistry
or a completely different field like
biophysics altogether so these two
courses are for them to gets to know or
get introduced to
bioinformatics and different comics data
types introduced to data science and get
introduced to structural biology that is
why these two courses are free and then
to access the other courses you have a
license involved because in
other courses you have a data analysis
practical sessions involved as well
which require you to take up the access
of the tv info server where you uh carry
out all the practical hands-on
hands-on analysis and on the server you
will be allocated five terabytes of
space so for the space and the license
it um
actually requires a specific fee to
maintain these particular spaces and
licenses that we are providing all right
so
doctor courses after your first you can
both go through them and then identify
and i identify a research interest and
then take it further
i hope i was able to answer question
project and
do we have any further questions
all right thank you
so if we have no more questions uh we
can end today's meeting
thank you clement we can end today's
meeting and uh we'll be now meeting on
august 25th for the second session
i will be meeting out the recording of
the session the resources that you have
to go through
and the assignment that you have to
complete all right and also i i will
share the link to join the skype group
please make sure that you join the skype
group if in case you face any technical
issue in joining please email us at
marketingcomicslogic.com
and for the participants of the program
please make sure that you have an
updated profile we require you to have
an updated profile so that we can
monitor your progress all right briona
please make sure that you have an
updated profile and also the other
participants
okay that was it
and you need to submit your assignment
on a marketing address
uh
only if you're not a program participant
if you are a program participant then
please email us on support at the
redbine.com
okay
that was it and uh hoping there are no
more questions as i can see in the chat
box we are good to end today's session
looking forward to